now the blm opening up public comment on  the proposed red rock legacy trail  tonight many neighbors are in support of  it though some want to make sure the  natural environment is not disturbed  i would like the blm to consider having  the legacy trail limit impact to any  existing natural surface trails in  calico either by running the legacy  trail trail parallel to these natural  surface trails or by creating re-routes  of these existing trails  the current review is for the stretch of  trail connecting part of summerlin to  the red rock fee station ultimately they  want to connect to mountains edge and  southern highlands you can weigh in on  this through may 9th